Do Androids Dream of Electric Sheep or
would they rather have a threesome with
their AI girlfriend and a sex worker
these moments are even better the second
time around
after the opening text crawl of Blade
Runner 2049 officer K arrives at the
farm home of an older replicant model
named sapper Morton this sequence moves
at a slow menacing Pace as they talk
around the fact that K has been sent to
eliminate the older model replicant if
you don't mind
if you could just look up into the left
please
saparosis the two brawl and before K
shoots him the older model tells the
officer one thing
because you've never seen a miracle Dave
Bautista's sapper is only in the movie
for the opening sequence but he makes
quite the impression he's a great
character to introduce Denise take on
the Blade Runner universe and his final
line has a hidden meaning when you see
the movie for a second time you'll
realize the miracle sapper references is
the child Deckard and Rachel have
together even though one of them is a
replicant and therefore supposedly
infertile it's too bad she won't live
but then again who does
blade runner's universe is indebted to
sci-fi and literature the original was
based on Philip K Dick's 1968 short
novel to Android's Dream of Electric
Sheep but Blade Runner 2049 also
contains a handful of direct references
to other pieces of literature the most
prominent example comes during the two
Baseline tests K is required to take
during the film all Blade Runners must
continually undergo post-traumatic tests
to ensure they are fit for Duty in both
instances the dialogue goes quickly
enough that it borders on nonsensical
during a first watch early in the movie
k-passes The Test later in the movie he
fails both times K is asked to recite
and repeat passages from Vladimir
nabokov's pale fire what's it like to
hold the hand of someone you love
interlinked
the 1962 poetic novel also comes up when
Joy brings the book to K asking if he
wants to read it both Works Do Androids
Dream of Electric Sheep and pale fire
explore the character's mortality but
there is a lot more ambiguity to it than
that the use of pale fire is never
explained but it has spawned a great
deal of thought and writing on the
connection between the novel and Blade
Runner 2049 one of the best scenes in
2049 is a seemingly innocuous moment
that ends up being the key to the whole
riddle in the middle of the film K
visits Anna stalene at her lab stalene
is a scientist who creates the false
memories that get implanted in
replicants K goes to her to ask about a
memory of his can you tell us something
really happened she watches it and
nearly weeps someone left this yes
this happened this scene really changes
on a second watch when you know that K
is not actually deckard's child at first
it seems like confirmation that K is
human and not a replicant a sub version
of the underlying twist in the original
Blade Runner but later it's revealed
that Rachel gave birth to a daughter as
K eventually discovers that daughter
grew up to be stalene which is why she
knew the memory was real and reacted to
it so strongly it was hers I can't help
your future but I can give you good
memories to think back on
smile
the primary B plot of Blade Runner 2049
focuses on K's relationship with his AI
girlfriend Joy the subplot explores the
boundaries of love and emotional
connection without a way to physically
connect despite this lack of literal
contact Kay and Joy's relationship has
plenty of figurative substance and they
love each other very much this Echoes
the themes of replicants and other AI
expressing love which are present in the
story of Deckard Rachel and their
daughter early in the film K meets
Mariette a sex worker who is later
revealed to be a part of the underground
replicant resistance in a scene that
made a lot of waves Joy hires Mariette
to be her physical body so she and K who
she affectionately calls Joe can make
love in the provocative scene Joy
projects herself onto mariette's body in
an uncanny special effect the brilliant
CGI truly gives the feeling that there
are three different people present in
the scene despite it being an intimate
encounter between a couple this sequence
Echoes many of the themes explored in
the 2013 movie her a story set in a
society where people are just beginning
to date their aios companions
the other mysterious literary reference
in Blade Runner 2049 comes when K breaks
into deckard's abandoned Vegas Hideout
and the two Blade Runners meet for the
first time after K finds Deckard he
steps out of the shadows and has some
Choice words
I didn't happen to have a
piece of cheese about you now
would you boy
this is a quote from Robert Lewis
Stevenson's Timeless Adventure novel
Treasure Island in Treasure Island this
line of dialogue is spoken by Ben Gunn
to the first man he sees after being
marooned for years the parallels to
Deckard are obvious once you know this
context the small detail is also a
callback to a deleted scene from the
original 1982 film in the scene Deckard
visits Holden in the hospital after
being shot by Leon what you reading
old favorite Treasure Island this adds
another referential layer to the scene
making it well worthy of a re-watch
one of the coolest sequences in 2049 is
the initial fight between Deckard and K
in the Vegas Hideout after setting off
one of deckard's traps K stumbles into a
lounge room or a malfunctioning hologram
plays a projection of Elvis Presley
performing on a stage the Hologram
flickers between Elvis and Marilyn
Monroe and back to Elvis before a
gunshot rings out in the club the
ensuing combat is chaotic and lit by
strobes and projections of dancers on
the tables it is incredibly dense
sometimes hard to follow and definitely
worth watching twice at the end of what
devolves into a fist fight Deckard says
something important Elvis's Can't Help
Falling in Love plays and the retired
Blade Runner notices
this moment is full of symbolism and
later in the movie Meander Wallace tells
us why did it never occur to you that's
why you were summoned in the first place
designed to do nothing short of fall for
her to what degree Meander is telling
the truth is unclear but using a song
with that title reinforces the idea that
Deckard had little choice but to fall in
love with Rachel
at the end of Blade Runner 2049 K fights
to rescue Deckard from The Wallace
Corporation and becomes mortally wounded
in the process having figured out
stalene is deckard's daughter he takes
the old man to our laboratory K sits
down on the steps outside the clinic for
one final bit of respite as the snow
falls it's a fate that upset and
Confused some fans but it is a very
intentional moment one that causes you
to reevaluate the character upon rewatch
for starters listen and you will hear
music playing that is extremely similar
to the soundtrack underneath Roy
baddie's famous Tears In The Rain dying
speech in the first Blade Runner I
seen things you people wouldn't believe
these two moments draw a through line
between the characters both Roy and Kay
ultimately saved Deckard in the end of
their stories and allow him to have a
happy ending this ending scene is a
callback to the original as well as a
parallel that emboldens 2049 as a sequel
in conversation with the original while
Roy died of looking downward in the rain
lamenting both his short life span and
his memories fading away K died looking
up to the snowy Sky presumably fulfilled
by bringing Deckard to his Miracle of a
daughter birthed by a replicant
[Music]